le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
la Réunion la croissance économique et
sociale a été fulgurante en seulement
quelques décennies
des changements de valeur et de repères
importants ont pu être modifiés ou
égratignés les priorités ont changé au
fil des générations cette métamorphose
an néanmoins offert à la Réunion une
situation économique performante ces
dernières années mais l'heure est à la
remise en question car la crise
économique est d'actualité beaucoup de
choses deviennent plus compliquées une
fatalité qui affecte le moral des
Réunionnais l'engagement personnel et
collectif on est diminué
pourtant qu'elle soit sportive
économique individuelle ou collective il
y a beaucoup de réussite à la réunion
des exemples qui démontrent que malgré
une époque difficile les Réunionnais
sont formidables
la situation géographique de la réunion
nous offre des avantages comme la
qualité de notre climat mais dans
certains cas cette éloignement peut être
un frein à nos ambitions
il faut donc redoubler d'efforts pour
aller au bout de ses rêves se battre
encore plus fort et surtout gardez
l'espoir et la confiance en soi les
difficultés de notre contexte social et
économiques peuvent parfois prendre le
dessus et nous empêcher de rêver ou de
garder toutes nos forces pourtant
certaines valeurs comme la combativité
le respect et l'estime de soi battre
très fort dans le cœur de certains
réunionnais Lucie
Ignace en est le parfait exemple à
seulement 19 ans elle a remporté le
titre de championne du monde de karaté
dans les sports de combat elle est la
seule avec Mike Tyson à avoir gagné ce
titre aussi jeune
Lucie s'entraîne à la Réunion loin du
reste de l'équipe de France un choix
qu'elle assume et qui ne l'empêche pas
de continuer de garder et d'améliorer
son niveau mais Lucie doit redoubler
d'efforts pour compenser l'éloignement
pour elle c'est une fierté de continuer
de s'entraîner à la Réunion malgré les
difficultés sociales et de représenter
son île dans les compétitions une
conviction qu'elle souhaite communiquer
aux jeunes futurs champions j'ai envie
de leur dire que ben il faut se fixer
des objectifs et il faut prendre exemple
sur les plus grands sur les plus les
plus titrés en guillemets pour les
sportifs et se dire aussi que moi je
peux y arriver comme moi je me suis dit
je regardais des grands sportifs
auparavant c'est vrai qu'on n'y croit
pas vraiment mais quand on se met un
objectif en tête on fait tout pour y
arriver et je veux leur dire qu'il faut
vraiment croire en leurs rêves et
qui peuvent y arriver les Réunionnais
sont formidables ça veut dire que malgré
la distance par rapport à la France pour
moi personnellement je suis loin de
l'équipe de France tout le monde
s'entraîne ensemble moi je suis la seule
à m'entraîner ici et donc du coup ben ça
peut on peut enfin il faut que je
travaille deux fois plus que pour
pouvoir réussir et aussi avoir un bon
niveau garder mon niveau donc du coup
pour moi être formidable ça veut dire se
donner les moyens quoi qu'il malgré la
distance malgré l'éloignement et comme
j'ai toujours dit toujours y croire
c'est un honneur pour moi de participer
à cet agenda avec tous les sportifs
réunis qui qui aiment et qui représente
le Real et c'est aussi pour montrer que
avec des efforts tu travailles du
courage on peut y arriver et on peut
atteindre ses objectifs et ses rêves la
Réunion est une terre aux multiples
talents dont les meilleurs ambassadeurs
sont de sportifs pays qui depuis des
décennies font autant rêver que vibrer
les coeurs des supporters que nous
sommes malgré l'éloignement de la
métropole et des grands centres
d'entraînement malgré les obstacles qui
ont pu se dresser devant eux ils n'ont
jamais baissé les bras au contraire ils
se sont battus ont gravit une à une les
marches du succès pour atteindre les
sommets et faire rayonner leur île au
plus haut niveau que ce soit en sport
individuel ou collectif leurs exploits
personnels sont immenses leurs histoires
sont magiques au point que les
superlatif peuvent nous manquer quand
nous voyons leur palmarès les
Réunionnais sont formidables et ça n'est
pas qu'un slogan il y a aujourd'hui des
potentialités existantes la jeunesse qui
réussit des adultes qui innovent croient
en leur pays et font des choses
extraordinaires que ce soit sur le plan
professionnel et même personnel ils sont
pas souvent mis en lumière et il y a
avec la crise une certaine morosité à la
Réunion les jeunes qui n'ont pas
d'emploi par exemple s'expriment souvent
à travers des questionnements de doute
de crainte et nous voulons cette année
montrer que les Réunionnais ils sont
formidables comme ils l'ont été avant
nous et nous allons décliner cette
thématique dans tous les sphères de la
vie publique au Conseil Général pour
mettre en place avec des parents mais
aussi des jeunes ceux qui sont déjà dans
l'activité reconnue en pleine lumière un
maillage pour préparer l'avenir lumineux
de la Réunion la Réunion nouvelle
le Conseil général a souhaité rendre
hommage et mettre en valeur celles et
ceux qui a force de courage de
persévérance et de détermination sont
devenus les portes drapeau de la réunion
de l'excellence des modèles de réussite
des exemples à suivre pour bon nombre
d'entre nous que ce soit dans le sport
dans les collectivités les entreprises
et dans bien d'autres domaines encore
certains continueront de nous prouver
qu'il ne faut pas se laisser envahir par
la morosité et continuer de se donner
les moyens d'atteindre ses rêves il faut
se prouver à soi-même et au reste du
monde que les Réunionnais sont
formidables
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais